This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Today we have three stories about designs meant to fool you, camouflage meant to fool you boats, highways designed to fool your brain into going way faster than it should want to, and impeccably made fake signs meant to guide you to the right freeway. Three classic favorite 99pis, completely updated, remixed, and rescored. Enjoy. I think if you ask somebody on the street, what is camouflage, I believe the most common answer would be to say, well, it's a figure and it's being hidden by being blended with its background. Scientists today call that background matching.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。今天我们有三个关于“欺骗”设计的故事：旨在迷惑敌人的伪装，旨在诱导你超速行驶的高速公路设计，以及为了引导你走上正确高速公路而制作的完美假路牌。这是三个经典的《99%隐形》节目，经过了全面的更新、重混和重新配乐。希望你喜欢。我想如果你问街上的人什么是伪装，我相信最常见的回答会是：嗯，那是一个物体通过与背景融合而隐藏起来。今天的科学家称之为“背景匹配”。
I call that high similarity camouflage. That's Roy Barron's. I'm Roy Barron's and I teach in the Department of Art at the University of Northern Iowa. I teach graphic design and the history of design. Barron's is also one of the foremost camouflage experts. Well, I wouldn't go that far. High similarity or blending is just one type of camouflage. It's kind of the boring one.
我称之为“高相似度伪装”。那是罗伊·巴伦斯的观点。我是罗伊·巴伦斯，我在北爱荷华大学艺术系任教。我教授平面设计和设计史。巴伦斯也是最顶尖的伪装专家之一。嗯，我不敢当。高相似度或融合只是伪装的一种。它算是比较无聊的那种。
But another type of camouflage that you can find both in nature and in military use is disruptive camouflage. I call it figure disruption. Figure disruption. Because it breaks up the figure. It's the opposite of high similarity camouflage. It's high difference. So you're making it very difficult for us
但另一种在自然界和军事中都能找到的伪装是“破坏性伪装”。我称之为“形态破坏”。形态破坏。因为它打碎了物体的形态。它与高相似度伪装正好相反。它是“高差异性”。所以你让人们很难
to look at the figure and to see it as only a single continuous thing. Corruption. Figure disruption. Zebra stripes have long been thought see it as only a single continuous thing. ZEBRAS TRIPES ZEBRAS TRIPES ZEBRAS TRIPES ZEBRAS TRIPES have long been thought to be a form of disruptive camouflage. The stripes make it harder for a predator to distinguish one zebra from another when the zebras are in a large herd.
去观察这个物体，并将其视为一个单一的连续整体。破坏。形态破坏。斑马条纹长期以来被认为……将其视为一个单一的连续整体。斑马条纹，斑马条纹，斑马条纹，斑马条纹，长期以来被认为是一种破坏性伪装。当斑马成群结队时，这些条纹让捕食者很难将一只斑马与另一只区分开来。
The stripes might also make zebras less attractive to blood-sucking horseflies, but I digress. But when it comes to humans, the greatest, most jaw-droppingly spectacular application of disruptive camouflage by the military is razzle-dazzle. Dazzle camouflage strictly applies to ship camouflage and even more strictly it applies to World War I ship camouflage. And it came about because it was discovered that it's almost impossible to make a ship invisible on the ocean. The horizon is changing in color, it's changing in amount of light. So there are all kinds of conditions that make it so a constantly moving ship can't blend into the background of the sea.
这些条纹可能还会让斑马对吸血的马蝇失去吸引力，但我跑题了。但说到人类，军事上最伟大、最令人瞠目结舌的破坏性伪装应用就是“眩目伪装”。眩目伪装严格来说适用于舰船伪装，甚至更严格地说，它适用于第一次世界大战期间的舰船伪装。它的出现是因为人们发现，让一艘船在海洋上隐形几乎是不可能的。地平线的颜色在变，光线强度也在变。所以各种条件使得一艘不断移动的船无法融入大海的背景中。
And even if you could make a ship invisible... You still have smoke coming out of the smokestack, so it's not as if you're hiding the ship at all. So the less not as if you're hiding the ship at all. So the less heavily armored ships were setting docks. The crisis came about at the time that the US had not yet entered the war. Remember, this is World War I. It was the British ships that were being sunk.
即使你能让一艘船隐形……烟囱里还是会冒出烟，所以你根本没能把船藏起来。所以那些装甲较弱的船只正在……所以你根本没能把船藏起来。所以那些装甲较弱的船只正在停靠码头。这场危机发生在美国尚未参战的时候。记住，这是第一次世界大战。当时被击沉的是英国船只。
And the German submarines were sinking as many as 50 ships a week. Many of those ships were merchant ships, and they were bringing supplies to England, which is an island, of course, and it really depended on those. And then also there was armaments and other things that were being secretly taken there, too.
德国潜艇每周击沉多达50艘船。其中许多是商船，它们为英国运送补给——英国当然是一个岛国，确实依赖这些补给。此外，还有秘密运往那里的军火和其他物资。
So the design solution was not about invisibility. It was about disruption. A number of artists decided that the best way to avoid getting torpedoed was not to make the ship invisible, but to make it hard to hit. That's why these kind of erratic, crazy quilt patterns came about, and that's why they were used in that war. It's gonna be hard to picture this, but I want you to try. There was once a time when military ships, even US ships by this point, were painted with, and I quote this from an anonymous
所以设计方案不是为了隐形。而是为了“破坏”。一些艺术家认为，避免被鱼雷击中的最好方法不是让船隐形，而是让它难以被瞄准。这就是为什么会出现这种古怪的、疯狂的拼布图案，也是为什么它们在那场战争中被使用。这很难想象，但我希望你试一试。曾经有一段时间，军舰，甚至包括当时美国自己的军舰，都被涂上了——我引用1918年《纽约时报》一篇匿名文章的话——任何纽约人都会看到，在进出港口时，无数船只的涂装展现出如此狂野、夸张的形状和色彩，让陆地居民惊愕不已，感到困惑。黑白配色非常普遍。它们由条纹、漩涡和类似新艺术运动风格的阿拉伯式花纹组成。蓝色被广泛使用，特别是在英国的版本中。但我认为你会对色彩的范围感到惊讶。
article from the New York Times from 1918, any New Yorker will see anchor, or coming in or out, numerous ships whose painted size reveals such wild extravagances of form and color as to make the landsman open his eyes with amazement and mystification. Black and white was very common. They consist of stripes and swirls and kind of arabesque, almost Art Nouveau shapes. Blue was used predominantly, especially in the British versions. But I think you'd be surprised at the range of colors.
还有有时会用到的红色、绿色，以及非常强烈的橙色。另一位未具名的美国记者写道：“你应该看看我们的舰队。它被伪装得看起来像一群远洋复活节彩蛋。”第一次世界大战期间，眩目舰船伪装对公众来说绝对是令人着迷的。
There were reds that were sometimes used and greens and really quite intense oranges. Another unidentified US journalist wrote, You should see our fleet. It's camouflaged so it looks like a flock of seagoing Easter eggs. During World War I, dazzle ship camouflage was absolutely fascinating to the public.
你必须记住，这发生在纽约所谓的“军械库展览”之后仅仅几年。这是美国第一次国际现代艺术展。它是立体主义、未来主义以及所有那些人们嘲笑的东西的入门展览。他们认为这些是艺术家们非常疯狂的发展方向。
You have to remember that this is happening just a few years after the, what's called the Armory Show in New York. It's the first international show of modern art in this country. And it was the introductory show of Cubism, Futurism, all of those things that people made fun of. And they thought that these are really crazy directions for artists to be going into.
所以当这种情况发生时，人们看着那些船说，哦，这是一场立体主义的噩梦。这是未来主义，他们已经接管了世界。正如你可能猜到的，有很多人讨厌眩目伪装，主要是传统的海军军官。他们把它比作妓女穿的衣服，并嘲笑它。
So that when this happened, people looked at those ships and they said, oh, it's a Cubist nightmare. It's futurist, they've taken over the world. As you can probably guess, there were plenty of people who hated dazzle camouflage, traditional Navy men mostly. They compared it to the clothing that a prostitute would wear and they made fun of it.
它的工作原理是这样的。我可以带你了解一下步骤。当时，从U型潜艇发射的鱼雷速度相当慢，可能需要几分钟才能到达目标。所以发射鱼雷的人必须预判目标。他必须预测鱼雷到达时目标船只会在哪里。所以他必须计算如何做到这一点，而这很大程度上取决于知道它前进的确切角度。
Here's how it worked. I can lead you through the steps. At the time, torpedoes fired from U-boats were quite slow, maybe taking a couple of minutes to reach their target. So the person firing the torpedo had to lead the target. He had to anticipate where the target ship was going to be when the torpedo arrived. So he had to calculate how to do that, and that very much depended on knowing the exact angle it's headed toward.
这非常非常重要。另一件事是你必须算出船的速度，因为这样你才知道鱼雷到达时它能走多远。眩目伪装确实让船只显得突出，但那些凸起的形状和鲜艳的色调也使得判断移动船只的速度和方向变得困难。它利用了我们关于物体越远看起来越小的假设。所以你可以在船上画出透视图案，让它看起来好像在向不同的方向转弯，
That's terribly terribly important. And the other thing is that you have to figure out the speed of the ship because then you'll know how far it can go by the time the torpedo gets there. The dazzle camouflage certainly made the ship stand out, but the bulging shapes and vivid hues also made it difficult to determine the speed and direction of the moving ship. It's preying on our assumptions about things looking smaller as they are more distant. So you could paint perspective patterns on a ship that would make it look like it was turning in a different direction
而实际上你看到的是它的正面，它们是绝对平坦的。眩目图案打碎了物体的形态，使它看起来比实际更短，或者让人难以分辨是一艘船还是多艘船。他们甚至在船上画了假的船首波，他们会把假船首波画在前面，让船看起来比实际行驶速度更快，因为那是计算速度的一种方式。或者他们会把船首波画在后面。所以当你通过潜望镜观察时，你可能会瞥一眼，然后
when in fact you're actually seeing them frontally and they're absolutely flat. The dazzle patterns broke up the figure so it could look like it was shorter than it really was or it could make it hard to tell if there was one ship or multiple ships. They even painted fake bow waves on them and they would paint the fake bow wave either on the front to make it look like the ship was going faster than it was actually going because that was one way of calculating that. Or they would paint the bow wave on the back. And so you would glance at it while you're looking through this periscope and you might
得出结论：哦，它在往那个方向走，而不是另一个方向。所以当你再次浮出水面计算射击位置时，目标已经不见了。它处于一个与你想象中完全不同的方向和位置。这些图案不仅仅是草率地涂在巨型船只的侧面，希望它们足够混乱以达到效果。
conclude that, oh, it's going in that direction, not in the other direction. So then you surface again to calculate where you're going to shoot, and the thing is gone. It's an entirely different direction and location than you imagined. These patterns weren't just slapped onto the side of giant ships, hoping that they'd be confusing enough to be effective.
伪装师——这就是他们的称呼——伪装师们通过邀请缺乏经验的潜艇艇长通过潜望镜观察并报告他们认为模型指向的角度来测试玩具模型。他们确定，有时在伪装得非常有效的船只上，船长的计算偏差可以高达55度。
Camouflures, and that's what they're called, the camouflures tested toy models by inviting inexperienced submarine captains to peer through periscopes and report what angle they thought the models were pointed. They determined that sometimes on really effectively camouflaged ships, the calculation of the ship captains could be off as much as 55 degrees.
眩目伪装只需要让鱼雷炮手的估计偏差八度，目标船只就能有效地避开鱼雷。战争的舞台已经改变，所以伪装也随之改变，但仍然可以找到眩目伪装的影子。事实上，如果你看看今天的军用舰艇，仍然有眩目伪装的应用。但当然，条件已经改变了。就像第一次世界大战一样，这是由那些特定的条件产生的。我们必须说，嗯，那些不是我们现在所处的条件，那么今天什么才是最有效的呢？如果你看飞机，它经常被分割开来。如果你看船只，其中一些通过这些几何图案被分割开来。
Dazzle only had to screw up the torpedo gunner's estimate by eight degrees for the target ship to effectively avoid a torpedo. The theater of war has changed, so camouflage has changed with it, but there is still dazzle to be found. Actually, if you look at military craft today, there is still dazzle being practiced. But of course, the conditions have changed. Just as in World War I, this came out of those particular set of conditions. We have to say, well, those aren't the conditions that we have now, so what would be most effective today? If you look at aircraft, it's broken up very often. If you look at ships, some of them are broken up through these geometric patterns.
如果你看一些伪装制服，世界各地的步兵制服，你会发现各种各样的眩目分割等等，或者坦克、卡车等等。但我很遗憾地报告，已经没有成群的远洋复活节彩蛋了。那是第65集《眩目伪装》。一位名叫迪伦·弗莱的99PI听众是威斯康星大学斯托特分校的平面设计系学生，他为一门课程项目制作了一份杂志格式的该集节目文字稿。这太酷了。我们会在节目说明和我们的网站上提供链接，那里还有大量你需要立刻去看的眩目伪装船只的照片。
If you look at some camouflage uniforms, infantry uniforms around the world, you'll find all kinds of break up with dazzle and so forth forth or tanks or trucks and so forth. But I am sad to report that there are no longer flocks of seagoing easter eggs. That was episode 65, Razzle Dazzle. A 99PI listener named Dylan Fry is a graphic design student at the University of Wisconsin Stout and for a class project he created a transcript of that episode in zine format. It is so cool. We'll have a link to it in the show notes and on our website where we also have tons of pictures of razzle dazzle ships which you need to go look at immediately.
它们会改变你的生活。接下来，另一个关于欺骗眼睛和大脑的故事，第68集《为速度而生》。我希望你在脑海中勾勒出白色条纹的图像。不是那些“白色条纹”乐队，而是划分高速公路上同向行驶车道的白色条纹。那些条纹有多长？如果你愿意，可以张开双臂估算一下。多年来，俄亥俄州立大学的一位心理学研究员丹尼斯·谢弗
They will change your life. Up next, another story of fooling the eye and fooling the mind, episode 68, Built for Speed. I want you to conjure an image in your mind of the white stripes. Not those white stripes, but the white stripes that divide the lanes of traffic going in the same direction on a major highway. How long are those stripes? You can spread your arms out to estimate if you want to. Over the course of many years, a psychology researcher named Dennis Schaeffer at Ohio State
问过全国各地许多学生这个问题。最常见的回答是两英尺。所以如果你像大多数人一样，你估计那些白色条纹有两英尺长，也许再多一点。但如果你这么想，你就大错特错了。这是汤姆·范德比尔特。我的名字是汤姆·范德比尔特。我是纽约的一名作家，也是《交通：我们为何这样开车以及它说明了什么》一书的作者。
asked students from many different parts of the country this question. And the most common response was two feet. So if you're like most people, you estimated that those white stripes are two feet long, maybe a little more. But if you did, you'd be very, very wrong. This is Tom Vanderbilt. My name is Tom Vanderbilt. I'm a writer in New York and author of Traffic, Why We Drive the Way We Do and What It Says
关于我们。汤姆那本精彩的《交通》书中的每一页，我可能都能把它变成一集《99%隐形》，但回到高速公路的话题。嗯，在我的研究早期，我曾与一位高速公路工程师交谈。他说，如果你的车在路边抛锚了。
About Us. Every three pages of Tom's terrific book, Traffic, I could probably turn into a 99% invisible episode, but back to the highway. Well, early on in my research, I was talking to a highway engineer. And he said, if your car is ever broken down on the side of the road.
如果你曾经被迫在高速公路上走出车外。花点时间注意一下这里的景观有多么奇怪。如果你恰好站在路标附近，这些路标非常巨大。我的意思是，它们不是为了让步行的人体验的。它们是为了让人们在时速75英里的情况下体验的。
You've ever been forced to get out of your vehicle on a highway. Just take a moment to notice how strange the landscape is. If you're just happen to be standing near a road sign, these road signs are huge. I mean, they're not meant to be experienced as humans on foot. They're meant to be experienced at 75 miles an hour.
使用那种清晰的Clearview字体。清晰可见，具有逆反射功能。还有那些白色条纹。如果你真的走出车外，能够走在封闭的高速公路上，从这些条纹的一端走到另一端，你会发现，我的意思是，多年前在美国，高速公路的标准是15英尺长，这比汽车本身还要长。目前的联邦公路管理局指南建议长度为10英尺，
With that clear view typeface. Perfectly visible, retro reflective. And then there are the white stripes. If you actually kind of got out of your car and were able to walk on a closed highway and walked from one end of those stripes to the other, you'd find that, I mean, years ago in the United States, the highway standard was 15 feet long, which is longer than a car itself. Current federal highway administration guidelines suggest a length of 10 feet,
虚线之间间隔30英尺。这让人们感到震惊。记住，谢弗研究中的大多数人说那些条纹有两英尺长。这中间有着巨大的鸿沟。这不像那种“它们实际上是五英尺，我们以为是两英尺”的误差范围。这回到了一个基本点：当你以高速在车里时，你体验到的只是景观的一种感觉，而不是真实的景观。
with 30 feet between the dashes. That's something that is shocking to people. And remember, most people in the Schaeffer study said that those stripes were two feet long. That's such a vast gulf there between. It's not sort of like, you know, they're actually five feet. We thought they were two, you know, margin of error kind of thing. And it goes back to this fundamental point that when you're in a car at high speeds, you're experiencing only a sense of the landscape rather than the actual landscape.
这种景观感被呈现给你，本质上是为了让你感到舒适。并使高速公路在对人类来说进化上极其荒谬的速度下运行。你拥有这种宽阔、平坦、开阔的道路，即使你有一个时速65英里的限速标志，道路传达的信息也完全不同。
This kind of sense of landscape has been presented to you to essentially make you feel comfortable. And to make a highway work in what are really evolutionarily ridiculous speeds for a human to travel. in what are really evolutionarily ridiculous speeds for a human to travel. You have this big, flat, wide open, kind of stretch of road that, even if you have a 65 mile an hour sign, the message of the road is telling you something entirely different.
我认为这确实是我们很多行为的来源。有时你有某种故意的超速，故意的违法，但很多时候只是人们在关注道路的视觉信息，而不是他们的速度表。长长的分割线和清晰的视野给人一种错觉，
And I think that's really where a lot of our behavior comes from. Sometimes you have sort of willful speeding, willful kind of law breaking, but a lot of it is just people are paying attention to the visual messaging of the road, not to their speedometer. Long dividing lines and clear vistas give the illusion
让你觉得自己在以合理的速度行驶。一旦有东西进入视野，你就会感觉到自己开得有多快。这就是为什么施工期间施工人员放在路边的那些临时混凝土墙如此令人不安的原因之一。对白色条纹长度的感知错误归因于这样一个事实：当我们开车在高速公路上时，我们倾向于看得太远，以至于我们通常只在它们非常遥远且呈一定角度时才体验到虚线和间隙，所以它们看起来更短。但对于为什么全国各地的人们在两英尺的估计上如此一致地出错，目前还没有共识。这已经成为我最喜欢的鸡尾酒会谈资之一。我也是。用这个白色条纹的信息难倒司机。我不想留下这种印象，
that you're going at a reasonable speed. As soon as something encroaches into view, you get a sense of how fast you're going. That's one reason why those temporary concrete walls that crews put up right next to the road during construction are so unnerving. The error in perception of white stripe length is attributed to the fact that when we drive on the highway, we tend to look so far ahead that we usually only experience the dashes
即宽阔的分割线是统一的。你不会在纽约市的林荫大道上找到10英尺长的高速公路标线。你也不会在桥梁或高速公路匝道上找到10或15英尺长的条纹。或者我们希望你找不到，因为那对于那个空间来说是一种完全不恰当的设计语言。受限高速公路的设计目的是非常精确的。高速公路是为了不间断、快速流动的交通而设计的。
and gaps when they are very far away and at an angle so they look shorter. But there's no consensus as to why people all over the country were so consistently wrong with the two feet estimate. It's, yeah, become my favorite, one of my favorite cocktail party facts. Mine too. Stump the driver with this white stripes information. I don't want to leave the impression
让人们尽可能快地从A点到达B点，没有任何中断。我的意思是，那种环境在城市或郊区是行不通的。问题在于当这种方法被移植到不属于它的地方时。我认为我们现在在一些郊区环境中正在为此付出代价，在那里你会发现这些动脉高速公路，它们几乎是按照高速公路工程标准建造的，同样有长长的视线、宽阔的道路，鼓励人们开快车。然后我们又在这些动脉高速公路沿线进行了各种开发，而这些开发本不应该在那里。随着这么多人在这些道路上行驶，它们对商业变得绝对不可抗拒。
that the wide dividing lines are uniform though. You won't find 10 foot highway lines on say a boulevard in New York City. And you You won't find 10-foot highway lines on, say, a boulevard in New York City. And you probably won't find 10 or 15-foot stripes on bridges or highway on-ramps. Or let's hope you don't, because that's an entirely inappropriate design language for that space. Limited-excess highways are designed for a very precise purpose. The highway is meant for uninterrupted, fast-flowing traffic.
这就像是新的美国主街，对吧？你有好市多、快餐店，还有各种各样的停车场、车道、免下车服务，但人们同时也开得非常快。埃里克·邓博做了很多研究，表明这些实际上是目前美国最危险的驾驶场所，而不是许多人认为的拥挤的城市。整个方法被称为“宽容道路”。这个想法是，你知道，首先尝试通过减少障碍物来尽量减少发生碰撞的可能性，
Get people from point A to point B as quickly as possible with no interruptions. I mean, that sort of environment does not work in cities or suburbs. The problem is when that approach is grafted into places where it doesn't belong. I think we're actually kind of paying the price for this right now in some suburban environments where you find these kind of arterial highways that were built almost to an highway engineering standard with again these long sight lines, wide roads encouraging people to go fast. And then we went and built all kinds of development along those arterial highways, which was never really supposed to be there. With so many people driving on these roads, they became absolutely irresistible to commerce.
你知道，宽阔的视线，所有这些东西。但如果碰撞确实发生了，也要减轻后果，不要因为司机不可避免会犯的错误而惩罚他。这是我引用当时的一些语言。所以你现在在加利福尼亚州等地看到这种情况，你会看到那种钢丝护栏，如果汽车撞上护栏，它往往会挂在护栏上，而不是被弹回交通流中，从而导致另一系列碰撞。所以这种宽容道路在良好的安全工程方面是一件积极的事情。
This is kind of the new American main street, right, where you have your Costco's and your fast food and all sorts of in and out parking lots, driveways, drive-throughs, yet people also going very fast. And Eric Dunbaugh does a lot of research suggesting that these are really some of the most dangerous places to currently drive in America, not crowded urban cities, which is what a lot of people would think. The whole approach is called the forgiving road. The idea was that, you know, to first try to minimize the potential that a crash could happen through again, again, through lack of obstacles,
但他们被它迷住了，以至于决定将其引入地面街道网络。所以像行道树这样的东西开始被工程师视为危险，完全就是危险。这在高速乡村道路上是有道理的，但如果你谈论的是住宅街道，无论如何你都不应该开超过25英里，那么路边提供遮荫和舒适感的行道树是同样的危险吗？它甚至是一种危险吗？
you know, generous sight lines, all these sorts of things. But then if a crash did happen to kind of mitigate the effects of what would happen to not punish the driver for the mistake that he will inevitably make. This was, I'm quoting some of the language from the time. So you see that nowadays in things like in California, you'll have your guard rails that are sort of wire guard rails that if a car strikes that guard rail, it tends to catch on the guard rail rather than being bounced back out into traffic, which causes another series of collisions. So this forgiving road is a positive thing in terms of good safety engineering.
许多规划者得出的结论是，是的，树木是危险的。你看看战前的郊区，你有街道、一排树，然后是人行道。战后，这种转变开始发生，树木被移到了人行道的另一侧。突然间，行人被置于司机和那些威胁性的树木之间的缓冲地带。这里发生了一件有害的事情，那就是当你移走那些树木时，道路的视觉感受变得更宽了。如果说交通工程有一条铁律的话，
But they were so sort of seduced by it that the call was made to bring it into even the surface street network. So things like street trees began to be deemed hazards by engineers, just outright hazards. And that makes sense on a high-speed country road, but if you're talking about residential street where you're not supposed to be going more than 25 anyway, is the presence of a street tree on the side of the road where it's providing shade and comfort to pedestrians, you know, is that the same sort of hazard? Is it even a hazard at all?
它也涉及到这种视觉感知，道路越宽，或者被认为越宽，司机的速度往往就越快。当然，如果你看看20世纪90年代的郊区，他们只是完全取消了人行道和树木。所以那是最后的解决方案，只是消除任何一种危险。汤姆·范德比尔特说，
The conclusion many planners came to was, yes, trees are a hazard. You find pre-war suburbs, you have the street, a set of trees, and then the sidewalk. Coast War, this sort of shift began to happen where the trees were moved on the other side of the sidewalk. Coast War, this sort of shift began to happen where the trees were moved on the other side of the sidewalk. Suddenly pedestrians were put in the position of being the buffer between drivers and those menacing trees. There was sort of a pernicious thing that happened here is that as you move those trees away, the visual sensation of the road became wider. And if there's one kind of iron law
你几乎可以根据这种转变来确定一个分区的开发时间。这指出了道路工程的一个问题，即人类倾向于消耗为他们的安全而内置的额外工程措施。我很喜欢用康奈尔大学布莱恩·万辛克在食品包装方面所做的一些研究来做类比。
of traffic engineering, it gets into this visual perception thing as well, the wider a road is or is perceived to be. The faster driver speed tends to increase. And of course, you know, the final, if you look at sort of 1990s era, you know, suburbia, that they just kind of eliminated the sidewalk and the trees altogether. So that was sort of the final, the final solution, just eliminate any kind of eliminated the sidewalk and the trees altogether. So that was sort of the final solution, just eliminate any kind of hazard. And Tom Vanderbilt says,
你做实验，如果你给人们，只是一群随机的人，装满爆米花的巨大桶，再给他们小包装里少量的爆米花，他们只会吃掉更多大包装里的。这与他们的饥饿程度无关。只是包装的大小影响了他们的行为。我认为我们的很多道路环境也是如此。它们为了安全而被过度设计，然后我们倾向于消耗掉很多额外的东西，让我们回到这种我们总是处于的稳态边缘，
you can almost date a subdivision's development based on that shift. And this points to one of the problems about road engineering is that humans tend to consume the extra engineering measures that have been built in for their safety. Much in the same way, I like to draw the analogy with some of the research that's been done on food packaging by Brian Wanzick at Cornell University.
我想。休息后，另一个重混经典《99PI》。我们回来了，带来记者大卫·温伯格的故事。这是第152集《游击公共服务》。在你生命中的某个时刻，你可能在建筑世界中遇到过一个问题，一些设计得很差的东西，而修复方法对你来说显而易见。也许是一扇开错方向的门，或者路上画得不好的标记。我一直注意到这类事情，在制作这个节目后更是如此。如果你也这样，我很抱歉，因为你听了这个节目。
You're doing experiments where if you give people, just random group of people, large buckets of popcorn filled to the top with popcorn and give them a smaller amount of popcorn in a smaller package, they'll just eat more of the larger package. It has nothing to do with their level of hunger. It's just the size of the package influences their behavior. I think a lot of our road environments are sort of like that. They're over-engineered for the safety and then we tend to consume a lot of the extras getting us back to this kind of homeostatic edge that we're always kind of playing with,
大多数时候，当我们看到这些东西时，我们在心里抱怨，然后什么也不做。我们产生惰性的原因有很多。我们不知道怎么修。这不是我们的工作。我们可能会惹上麻烦。那是制片人大卫·温伯格。你可能会注意到这些小的设计缺陷
I think. Another Remix Classic 99PIPI after the break. We're back with the story from reporter David Weinberg. This is episode 152, Guerrilla Public Service. At some point in your life, you've probably encountered a problem in the built world, something that was poorly designed and the fix was obvious to you. Maybe a door that opened the wrong way or a poorly painted marker on the road. I notice this kind of stuff all the time, even more so now after creating this show. I'm sorry if you do too, because you listen to this show.
多年来，默默地愤怒。直到有一天。他打电话给我说，你知道，好吧，我们要做了。那是2001年8月5日，星期日清晨，加利福尼亚州洛杉矶。理查德·安克拉姆和一群朋友在110号高速公路上的第四街大桥上。他们即将犯罪。这是一次高调、危险的情况。
And mostly when we see these things, we grumble on the inside and then do nothing. There are all sorts of reasons for our inertia. We don't know how to fix it. It's not ours to fix. We could get in trouble. That's producer David Weinberg. You might notice these little design flaws
我不仅可能被捕，还可能杀人。真的，我对此感到恐惧。但让我们回顾一下。大约20年前，住在奥兰治县的艺术家理查德·安克拉姆正开车在110号高速公路上向北行驶。当他经过洛杉矶市中心时，他打算并入另一条高速公路，即5号州际公路北向。但他错过了出口，迷路了。出于某种原因，这件事一直困扰着他。
for years, silently fuming. Until one day. He called me and said, you know, okay, we're doing it. It was early Sunday morning, August 5, 2001, in Los Angeles, California. Richard Ancrum and a group of friends were on the Fourth Street Bridge over the 110 Freeway. They were about to commit a crime. and a group of friends were on the 4th Street Bridge over the 110 Freeway. They were about to commit a crime. It's going to be a high profile, dangerous situation.
多年后，当理查德搬到洛杉矶市中心时，他正开在十年前迷路的那段高速公路上，他抬头看向悬挂在上方的大型绿色长方形标志。我意识到我错过出口的原因是它没有足够的标志。糟糕的寻路系统。5号州际公路的出口没有在绿色高架标志上标明。甚至还有一个很大的空位，
Not only could I get arrested, I could kill somebody. Really, I was terrified of that. But let's back up. About 20 years prior, Richard Ancrum, an artist living in Orange County, was driving north on the 110 Freeway. As he passed through downtown Los Angeles, he was going to merge onto another freeway, the I-5 North. But he missed the exit and got lost. And for some reason, it just stuck with him.
那里本应该有一个蓝红相间的州际公路盾牌，上面应该写着“北”。理查德很清楚，加州交通局（Caltrans）犯了一个错误。所以理查德，一位艺术家和招牌画家，决定自己制作5号州际公路北向盾牌，并把它安装在他认为它一直应该在的地方，即110号高速公路的高处。他称之为“游击公共服务”行为。整个想法是成为某种公务员，
Years later, when Richard moved to downtown Los Angeles, he was driving on the same stretch of freeway where he'd gotten lost a decade before, when he looked up at the big green rectangular sign suspended above. I realized why I missed the exit is because it wasn't adequately signed. Bad wayfinding. The exit for the I-5 wasn't indicated on the green overhead sign. There was even a big open space
或者实际上是展示你能用艺术品做什么。你可以把它放在显眼的地方，让它成为每个人都能使用的功能性东西。理查德首先研究了洛杉矶的高速公路标志，拿着潘通色卡来完美匹配油漆颜色。他悬挂在桥梁上测量其他标志的确切尺寸。
where there should have been a blue and red interstate shield and above that it should have said north. It was clear to Richard that Caltrans, the California Department of Transportation, had made a mistake. So Richard, an artist and sign painter, decided to make the Interstate 5 North Shield himself and install it in the place he thought it should have been all along, high above the 110 freeway. He would call it an act of guerrilla public service. The whole idea was to be sort of a public servant
最重要的是，他下载了加州道路标志的“死灵之书”，即《统一交通控制设备手册》（MUTCD）。引用：“为加州所有官方交通控制设备提供统一的标准和规范。”这不是一本海滩读物。我把它当作一个慵懒的周日下午读物。所有的规格都在网上，所以人们可以竞标项目。
or actually to show what you can do with artwork. You can put it in plain sight and have a functioning working thing for everyone to use. Richard started by studying LA freeway signs, holding up Pantone swatches to perfectly match the paint color. He dangled over bridges to measure the exact dimensions of other signs.
理查德希望他的标志能按照加州交通局的确切规格建造，这些规格旨在让高速行驶的驾驶员阅读。带有数字5的盾牌大约有三英尺高和宽。它不到八分之一英寸厚，几乎只有八分之一英寸厚的铝板。它仍然相当坚固。在它上面我放了“北”这个词，大约14英寸乘5英尺。同样，我使用了那里现有的字体和标志。我尽量匹配所有东西，这样就不会明显看出不是加州交通局做的。理查德全新的添加物必须与现有的
And most importantly, he downloaded the Necronomicon of California Road signage, the Mutt Kid. The M-U-T-C-D, the manual on uniform traffic control devices. Quote, to provide for uniform standards and specifications for all official traffic control devices in California. It's not a beach read. I have it as more of a lazy Sunday afternoon read. All the specs are online so people can bid on projects.
标志完美融合，这些标志已经积攒了数十年的灰尘和烟雾。他们用一层非常薄的灰色釉料喷涂了整个东西。他们去掉了光泽。完成后，理查德用黑色记号笔在背面签上了自己的名字，就像画家在画布上签名一样。接下来是项目的下一阶段，安装，他像策划银行抢劫一样精确地计划了这次安装。他买了一套伪装，一顶白色安全帽和一件橙色背心，这样他看起来就像加州交通局的工人。
Richard wanted his sign to be built to the exact specifications of Caltrans, which were sign to be built to the exact specifications of Caltrans which were designed to be read by motorists traveling at high speeds. The shield with a five on it is three feet roughly high and wide. It's less than an eighth of an inch, barely an eighth of an inch thick aluminum. It's still pretty strong. And above that I put the word North and that was oh about 14 inches by five feet. And again I used the same typeface that was there and the same signs. I tried to match everything as close as I could so it wouldn't be obvious Calfrans didn't do it. Richard's brand new additions had to blend in perfectly with the existing
基本上尽可能地扮演好这个角色。他为他的皮卡车做了一个贴纸，看起来有点官方，上面写着“审美解构”。安装前一天晚上，理查德开车到现场，藏好了一些补给品，这样第二天早上很容易拿到。
signage which had been collecting dirt and smog for decades. They sprayed the whole thing with a really thin glaze of gray. They knocked down the shine. After he finished it, Richard signed his name on the back of it with a black marker, like a painter signing a canvas. Then came the next phase of the project, the installation, which he planned with the precision of a bank heist. He bought a disguise, a white hard hat and an orange vest, so he'd look like a Caltrans worker.
当我采访他时，他带我去了那个地方，并向我展示了他藏东西的地方。基本上就在这里，现在常春藤没那么厚，但当时厚得多，我把梯子和标志之类的东西藏在那棵树后面。藏好东西后，他爬上一棵树，坐在那里，在脑海中过了一遍所有事情。
Basically looked the part as best I could. And he made a decal for his pickup truck, meant to look vaguely official that said, aesthetic deconstruction. The night before the installation, Richard drove out to the site and hid some of his supplies so they'd be easy to get to the next morning.
我只是通过待在那里，前一天晚上和它待在一起，让自己平静下来。理查德担心他可能会把标志或工具掉到下面的路上。以时速60英里以上行驶的司机如果看到东西掉在他们面前的路上，或者更糟的是掉在他们的车上，将没有时间反应。这是整个项目中最可怕的事情，
When I interviewed him, he took me to the spot and showed me where he'd stashed his stuff. Basically here, and right now the ivy isn't that thick, but it was a lot thicker, and I had, well basically behind that tree it stashed the ladder and the signs and stuff. After he hid his things, he climbed a tree and just sat there, going through everything in his head.
如果有人受伤，你知道，我必须带着这种愧疚生活。而且项目我也得放弃，因为它违背了整个想法。但尽管有一些保留意见，理查德还是相当自信他能完成这一切。而且他已经走得太远，无法回头了。这把我们带回了2001年8月5日的早晨。理查德并不是一个人行动。他请了几位朋友从不同的角度拍摄安装过程。艾米·伊诺亚是他招募来拍摄的朋友之一。
I just sort of calmed myself down by being there and hanging around with it the night before. Richard was worried that he might drop the sign or one of his tools onto the road below. Drivers going 60 plus miles an hour would have no time to react if something landed on the road in front of them or worse onto their car. That was the scariest thing of the whole project
我们在周日早上6点或7点做的。当时很紧张，因为我们都以为会惹上麻烦。理查德选择周日早上安装标志，因为他知道交通很少，而且摩天大楼上升起的晨光非常适合拍摄。他没预料到的是，加州交通局也选了那个早上在那段高速公路上施工。是的，他们碰巧在那块标志南面的高速公路上做其他工作。当他们看到加州交通局的工人时，他们想过回头。
is if somebody got hurt, you know, I'd have to live with that. And then the project I'd have to sh-t can it because it would have defeated the whole idea of it. But despite some reservations, Richard was pretty confident he could pull the whole thing off. And he'd gone too far to turn back. And that brings us back to the morning of August 5th, 2001. Richard did not act alone. He asked several friends to film the installation from different vantage points. Amy Inoa was one of the friends he enlisted to film.
但我推测，毕竟这是一个相当大的城市，应该不止一个标志施工队。我的假设是他们会以为是另一队人在做。理查德停好卡车，当每个人都在摄像机位置就位后，他开始工作。最困难的部分实际上是带着梯子翻过铁丝网。一旦他上了猫道，距离高速公路近30英尺高，他开始拧上新标志，小心不要把任何螺丝掉在下面的车上。进行到一半时，我们觉得，好吧，他会成功的。看那个。那太神奇了，不是吗？哦，看，他在收他的东西。他装好了。整个过程不到30分钟。一旦
We did it at 6am or 7am on a Sunday morning. It was tense because we all thought we were going to get into trouble. Richard had chosen a Sunday morning to put up the sign, knowing that there would be little traffic and the morning light rising above the skyscrapers would be just right for filming. What he hadn't anticipated was that Caltrans had also picked that morning to do work on the same stretch of highway. Yes, they happened to be doing some other work on the freeway just south of that sign. When they saw the Caltrans workers, they thought about turning back.
它装好了，理查德收拾好梯子，冲回他的卡车，融入了城市。哇。天哪。太棒了。我想我们之后一起去吃了早餐，我们感到超级如释重负，真的很高兴。只有一小群人知道悬挂在110号高速公路上的带有“北”字的5号州际公路盾牌是伪造的。他没有对我们说，不要告诉任何人。
But I had surmised, after all this is a pretty large city, there'd be more than one sign crew. My assumption was they'd think the other guy was doing it. Richard parked his truck, and when everyone was in position with their cameras, he went to work. The hardest part really was getting over the razor wire with the ladder. Once he was up on the catwalk, nearly 30 feet above the highway, he started screwing in the new sign, careful not to drop any screws on the cars below. Halfway into it, we just felt like, okay, he's gonna get away with it. Look at that. Is that amazing or what? Oh, look, he's folding up his stuff. He's got it up. The whole thing took less than 30 minutes. As soon
所以我们的朋友都知道这件事，我们会开车经过它，我们都会为此感到非常高兴。但它从未设法泄露给那个小圈子之外的人。有一段时间。有一段时间。有一段时间。九个月来，这个秘密一直保存在一个小群体内。然后理查德的朋友加里泄露了这个故事。哦，搞什么鬼，加里？
as it was up, Richard packed up his ladder, rushed back to his truck and blended back into the city. Wow. Oh my God. Awesome. I think we all went out to breakfast together afterwards and we were super relieved and really happy. Only a small group of people knew that the Interstate 5 shield with the word North hanging above the 110 freeway was a forgery. He didn't say to us, don't tell anyone.
你为什么不能酷一点？酷一点，加里。理查德的秘密被加州交通局和媒体知道了。从他那辆破旧蓝色卡车上的假磁性标志，到一份宣称“紧急”的工作单。他的行为是违法的，但加州交通局表示根本没有计划对他提出指控。
So our friends all knew about it and we would drive by it and we would just all feel really happy about it. But it never sort of managed to leak out past that small group. For a while. For a while. For a while. For nine months, the secret stayed within a small community. And then Richard's friend, Gary, leaked the story. Oh, what the hell, Gary?
在他们发现发生了什么事后，显然他们派了一个施工队去检查。理查德希望在加州交通局拆除后能拿回他的标志。他想把它挂在艺术画廊里，但加州交通局没有拆除标志。它通过了加州交通局的检查，因为那确实是艺术品质量的最终测试。它挂了八年、九个月零14天，我相信。这不完全准确，
Why can't you be cool? Just be cool, Gary. Richard's secret was out to Caltrans and to the press. From the fake magnetic sign on his beat up blue truck to a work order proclaiming rush. What he did is against the law, but Caltrans says it has no plans at all to file charges against him.
但非常接近。在接受其他新闻机构关于此事的采访时，加州交通局并没有完全宽恕理查德的手艺，但他们对此相当客气。这是当时的加州交通局发言人。他做得很好，但我们不希望他再做一次。事实上，他做得太好了，我想给他提供一份工作申请。在理查德的标志挂上去八年多后，他接到一个朋友的电话，说看到一些工人在拆除它。
After they found out what had happened, apparently they sent a crew out there to inspect it. Richard was hoping to get his sign back from Caltrans after they took it down. He was thinking he would hang it in an art gallery, but Caltrans didn't take the sign down. It passed the Caltrans inspection because that's really the final test of how good the artwork is. It stayed up for eight years, nine months, and 14 days, I believe. It's not exactly accurate,
理查德联系加州交通局询问是否能拿回他的标志。当我找到他时，它已经被压成一捆运往中国了。谁知道它变成了什么？它现在可能是一个华夫饼机。加州交通局拆除理查德的标志后，用一个新的替换了它。但这次他们把他的想法融入了新设计中。他们添加了
but it's pretty close to that. In interviews about the incident with other news organizations, Caltrans didn't exactly condone Richard's handiwork, but they were pretty kind about it. Here's the Caltrans spokesperson at the time. He did a good job, but we don't want him to do it again. And in fact, he did such a good job that I'd like to offer him a job application. More than eight years after Richard's sign went up, he got a call from a friend who noticed some workers taking it down.
5号北向和盾牌，不仅在那块标志上，还在路上的另外两块标志上。一个小尾声。理查德的高速公路标志是一个幸福结局的故事。标志起作用了。人们很欣赏它。谢天谢地，没有人受伤。甚至加州交通局对这件事也真的相当不错。纽约市还有另一个游击标志的故事。
Richard contacted Caltrans to ask if he could have his sign back. By the time I tracked him down, it had already been crushed into a bale going for China. And who knows what it turned into? It could be a waffle iron by now. After Caltrans took down Richard's sign, they replaced it with a brand new one. But this time they incorporated his ideas into the new design. They added the
理查德联系了加州交通局，询问是否能拿回他的标志牌。等我找到他时，它已经被压成捆，正运往中国。谁知道它变成了什么？现在可能已经变成华夫饼机了。加州交通局拆除理查德的标志牌后，换上了一个全新的。但这次他们把他的想法融入了新设计中。他们添加了
Five North and the Shield not only to that sign but to two additional ones up the road. A little epilogue. Richard's Highway Sign is a happily ever after story. The sign worked. People appreciated it. No one got hurt, thankfully. Even Caltrans was really pretty nice about the whole thing. There's another Gorilla Sign story out of New York City.
五号公路北向标志和盾形标志，不仅加在了那个标志牌上，还加在了路上的另外两个标志牌上。一个小尾声。理查德的高速公路标志牌是一个圆满的结局故事。标志牌起作用了。人们很欣赏它。谢天谢地，没有人受伤。甚至加州交通局对整件事的处理也非常友善。纽约市还有另一个关于“大猩猩标志牌”的故事。
A group that calls itself the Efficient Passenger Project has been hanging signs in New York's subway stations to tell people where they can board the train to make the most efficient transfers. The project is not at all affiliated with the Metropolitan Transit Authority, but the signs look just like MTA signs, black with white Helvetica lettering. They say things like, board here for best transfer to the four, five, and six trains, or board here for best transfer to F and M trains. It's the kind of knowledge that you build up over time as a regular subway rider and this gorilla sign maker is offering it to everyone. And though some have applauded
一个自称为“高效乘客项目”的团体一直在纽约地铁站张贴标语，告诉人们在哪里上车可以实现最高效的换乘。该项目与大都会运输署（MTA）毫无关联，但这些标语看起来和MTA的标语一模一样，都是黑底白色的Helvetica字体。它们写着诸如“在此上车，可最便捷地换乘4、5、6号线”或“在此上车，可最便捷地换乘F和M线”之类的内容。这是一种作为地铁常客随着时间推移而积累的知识，而这个“游击队”标语制作者正将其提供给所有人。尽管有些人对此表示赞赏，
the signs not all New Yorkers are pleased. These are secrets some say that people should have to earn. They will unbalance the cars they say leave signage to the experts. The MTA, for their part, is taking down the signs as fast as they go up. MTA spokesman, Kevin Ortiz, told us in an email that, quote, posting of the signs is considered an act of vandalism.
但并非所有纽约人都感到高兴。有些人说，这些是人们应该通过经验获得的秘密。他们说，这会使车厢载客不平衡，应该把标语留给专家。而MTA方面，则在标语出现后迅速将其拆除。MTA发言人凯文·奥尔蒂斯在给我们的电子邮件中表示，引用原文，“张贴这些标语被视为一种破坏公物的行为”。
Point being, if you decide to undertake an act of guerrilla public service, just know, it may not be received as such. That episode, Guerrilla Public Service, first aired in 2014. This episode was remixed by Martín González and scored by Swan Real. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, Delaney Hall is the senior editor. Taylor Shedrick is our intern. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon,
重点是，如果你决定进行某种“游击式”的公共服务，要知道，它可能并不会被视为善举。那一集《游击式公共服务》于2014年首次播出。本集由马丁·冈萨雷斯重新混音，斯旺·里尔配乐。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监，德莱尼·霍尔是高级编辑。泰勒·谢德里克是我们的实习生。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁贝、杰森·德里昂，
Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Bosch Madone, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Gladney, Kelly Prime, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Nina Potuck, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. Home of the Oakland Roots Soccer Club, of which I'm a proud community owner. Other teams may come and go, but the Roots are Oakland first. Always.
埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·莱、博世·马多内、乔·罗森伯格、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、凯利·普莱姆、雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳、尼娜·波图克，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。99% Invisible的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区外的潘多拉大楼。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。这里是奥克兰根基足球俱乐部的所在地，我很自豪能成为该俱乐部的社区所有者之一。其他球队可能会来来去去，但根基队永远属于奥克兰。永远如此。
You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server where we are dropping our hot takes about Megalopolis and how the movie relates to the power broker. It's good stuff. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99i.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们，也可以加入我们的Discord服务器，我们在那里分享关于《大都会》的热门观点，以及这部电影与《权力掮客》之间的联系。内容很棒。在99pi.org上可以找到相关链接以及99PI的所有往期节目。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。